when I first heard about the quarters I
was appalled you know I got in law
enforcement cuz I wanted to serve from
from sag not be a bully you're way
beyond encouraging productivity at this
point now you're you know you're you're
encouraging police officers to act
unlawfully Auburn Alabama is home to
sprawling plains the Auburn University
Tigers and a questionable police force
after the arrival of a new police chief
in 2010 the department entered an era of
ticket quotas a common thread tying
Auburn PD to other departments in
Alabama and even nationwide Air Force
veteran an Auburn native Justin Hannah's
was a police officer on the force who
felt compelled to speak out the role
police in society I believe are to
interfere with the lives of the people
as little as possible but protect them
from you know the 1% element that wants
to victimize them you know let them be
free to live their lives but protect the
people and the property that's that's
what they pay us to do when I first
started in 2006 everything was great
morale was high the officers we had
cookouts together worked hard and you
know we pushed each other to be our best
and you know had great relationship with
the public but in 2010 things just
immediately took a turn Auburn pd's new
police chief chief Dawson had new
priorities and new marching orders
orders that the teen of command obeyed
without objection Justin recorded
conversations between his sergeant
sergeant Neil and the other officers to
keep tabs on any foul play it came in
and you know they immediately started
pushing for tickets I will have 100
contacts per month for men on 40 of
those lady warnings for traffic doesn't
seek to be divided between traffic
citations non traffic citations
custodial arrest do not be one that
there's nothing to hungry that's 72,000
contacts a year like a 50,000 person
town one thing sergeant Neil did was the
rod and carrot method you know if you
didn't get the the number of tickets he
wanted if you didn't get the hundred
contacts you get mandatory overtime you
know you get written up but if you did
do well the officer who wrote the most
tickets and the one that came in second
we're giving gift cards like steak
dinners and things like that
quotas pervert police priorities Radley
Balko is an investigative journalist for
the Huffington Post and author of the
new book rise of the warrior cop he says
that these quotas are an invitation to
corruption and bad policing there's
gonna be a strong incentive for police
officers may be defined offenses where
they didn't exist sergeant Neil started
instructing me and my partner to arrest
people that we didn't feel like it broke
the law
it was one I think was like maybe Friday
or Saturday night one the big bar nights
we saw a guy walking on the sidewalk
he was staggering a little bit but it
was you know walking quietly to himself
he was on the sidewalk wasn't stepping
out in the street it's not well it's
clear he's been drinking and will at
least contact and make sure he's okay so
we get out on them we contact him he
knows who he is where he is where he's
going we determined that he's good to go
we let him go well our sergeant saw it
and told us to go back and arrest him he
pointed to me and said you need it for
your stats so I told him it's not about
what I need it's about what he needs and
he doesn't need to go to jail so he got
out the car and you know you know
ordered us to arrest them and I still
refused my partner
you know scared for his job you know
went ahead and arrested the guy took him
to jail for public intoxication so you
have a policy that encourages police to
create petty crimes and to ignore
serious crimes and that's I mean that's
clearly the the very opposite of we want
what we want police officers to be doing
justin repeatedly expressed his concern
about the quotas and the way things are
being handled to his entire chain of
command he followed up with a formal
grievance process of a director of
Public Safety but to no avail
the director said that these
requirements were necessary for
increasing productivity you have to
question the leadership there if
officers need to have that sort of
incentive just to perform their jobs I
think personally that is revenue driven
at the same time that they're trying to
raise property taxes at the same time
they're trying to raise sales taxes
they're pushing us to get more tickets
and they're telling us they don't want
these little fix-it tickets they tell us
that they won't quote meet tickets
something with a fine they look over
your track traffic log and if you've got
a bunch of low fun or no fine tickets
they're going to tell you to switch and
do more speeding more red lights more
more you know things like that there's
not that many speeders there's not that
many people running a red light to get
those numbers so what officers do is
lower their standards when you're
issuing citations you're forcibly taking
money from people from citizens and
you're you know you're putting points on
their driving records I mean you're
inhibiting their freedom and a lot of
ways these kind of policies that the
ticket quotas and the heavy hand
enforcement will affect the the
lower-income population is the most when
you write somebody two or three hundred
sixty-four dollar tickets in a month
they've got to make some choices that
month
that's you know that that's you know
groceries you know that's maybe food or
clothes for kids that might be you know
car house payment it wasn't long before
Justin had to start worrying about his
own finances after the department made
it clear that if he continues to speak
out it would cost him his job during the
grievance process they try to squash it
on a technicality you know they tried to
talk me out of it you know try to
buddy-buddy up with him to get it to
drop it and they once all else failed
they started threatening my job my
career warned me there'd be consequences
for doing this I had no intention of
dropping you know at this point I had no
choice I think I had to keep going
forward and if I stopped and nothing
would have change there's just been
another your minor hiccup justin was
fired and while the department declined
reason TVs requests for information on
the case Justin says he was ultimately
fired for violating a gag order when
they call me in fired me the first thing
that went through my mind was my kids
you know I'm a primary breadwinner I
don't know how the Builder gonna get
paid and you know I didn't know what I
was gonna do as far as a new career you
know all my eggs are in this law
enforcement basket knows what my calling
was it's what I've always wanted to do
justin hasn't found a new job he's
currently looking for a lawyer to take
up his case and sued the department
though after reaching out to the Police
Benevolent Association for guidance he
found out that his grievances were
actually pretty common
they're like basically here we go with
this skins it's a problem in more places
than Auburn this is a frequently
occurring thing and it's about it with a
lot of different officers and
departments well justin will continue
his battle on the legal front he thinks
that the fastest way to get the city
back on track is public accountability
once the people know they can hold their
elected officials accountable and then
it'll change you know officers have
tried for years to change it from the
inside and they're either forced out or
just leave from frustration and and what
you end up with is a police department
where the good officers have been run
off and you have a bunch of officer just
willing to play the game they want to be
the bullies you know they want to show
how bad they over the badge and that's
what you get left
[Music]
you